S
LET'S GO.".M ERIN B
HEG .
PUL LAW NOHI
FFT IN OF
UKRAINE JUST AFTIDAD
DOING THE MOVE NOTEERUSSIA SCE
AND THIS OFE
FIRST, DEG L
ORRUSSIAN-BACKED LEADERS TLEY AN
SWEEPING NEW RESTRICTIONS.
R LIANSSRPRETATION.
PUTIN COULD TAKEHEEWPOWERS EVEN.
ALNOW IS WT
TODAY.raTOE VERYLTE-SCALE TASKSE
TU
RITIESR TO DRAINIANS TT AIT
FORCES.
PE.T THINK A TT.FOE RATO FIGST
ORDERS
WANTED TEMPHASIZE.
THEY GWI R
O ALS RO ARUALL OFOT
EAALLOELL,S
TRANSFORMIOINACL ST
>>HALEERSIDENT BIDEN TODAY.
FINDS HIMSELF IN AN INCREDIBLY
DIFFICULOND T REFLECTS T SEEMSI.
TO INTI
CAPITULATING.
THEY ARE NOT GNGDOUTIN'SD AMPEDS
COMING FIRE.
WATCH TH>> Reporter: WE'RE GOINT
TT THERE AREN'T ANYUS
>> I'MOI TK TO FRED IN
BES ORDERS,
MARTOM HIS
COMING A
GGGEPUTIN AT HOME.
IN THE DAILY NEWSPAPER
IT.SSIAIA ITS
H LARGER NATIONWID
PROBLEM THE ON THE
LEVELS.
SOCIPSYCHOLOGICAL,MANAGERIAL, EA
IE THE CRUCIAL WORDS,
D LISTEN TO WHAT WAS SAION
SSIAST BY A
WAR CORRESPONDENT. Translator:
E SUBSTAL.
OME FRONT NEENBER OUR FORCES.D
EFFECT, A OR SO HAT,
POSSIBLE TO TURN TIDON
WAR.
EER
>> RorLIS TODAY SHOWS THE INCREN
I THINYOU'REHT.
THERE IS CERTAINL
HE
RU
UKRAINE.
THE PA TEN SO WE'VE  ALL THE STH
IMPORTANINUCRE H
WITH POWER PLANTS BEING T,
LONGANGE STRIKES BEIUCSIANS WEL
A LOILLERY BECAUSEALS AN
THEY WANTO TAKSTRATEGIC
TOWN.
TO
STOP THEM.
WE DID GET IN THERE TODAY.
HE W SAW ENTERING HERE, THE NEE
ING STRAIGHT INTOFOST DANGEROUSY
MEDIC WHO GOES BY A CALL
.R A NEARLY CONSTANT
HA'T TN AS
FULL STOP WHEN FHELL
HITSE OPS.
WE NEER AS BEST
>> WE'RE WAI
WAIT THATHENY H CLOSE M
F GUNFIRE
>> Reporter: ATH
RECEIVING EN A FULSS
IST RICHARD
OVER OUR HEAD.S UKRAINIAN TROO
VERAL
S A DAY.RTILLERY
QUIET. HAPPEN E
OTHER RT CIT
HITS MANY TIMEDAY.
THERE ARE TIMEEN
>> ReporBAND WASIN AUT
KILLED HERE WHILIAN  HAVE
BEEN GNG IN MANYLA
THINGS ARE DFE
T THEY ACKNOWLED
THSSIANS HAVE MORE ARTILLERY
ANARS  THE PRIVATE MILITARY
N WITHARTILLERY FLYING S
SAYS HERISN'
.
>> TUT WPRAISE O
UNFORTUN DAY PEOPLARE T OFDEAD D
EVERY RTE LINE.
>> Reporte T FG HERE
HAS THN
AND LEFT THE FEWPLO
REMAIND.
SERGEI DOESN'T EVEN TAKEASESN
NEARBY.
EVERYTHING WILL  MRA.lator: AFR?
EVYT FINE. R PAUSE IN THE  GIVE
KRAINIAN TANKS ROLHETH TTY FRO .
>> Reporter: YOU KNOW,HA
COMBATSON
TAHAPLACE.ELY, IN THCEE RUSSIANR
E UKRAINIANS ATHEM IS EXTREMELF.
SO GLAD THATND
E HT.
I WANT TO IA
ICN BREAKINGEWES.OCKED  RUSSIA.C
S
PUF S ME.HE
DIRECTOR OF THE
ST
FOMENT
DAED, COMINGEARLIE
TODAY, YOU CAN HEAR THNT
OF ARTILLERY THEUSG RAINIANS A .
E SL
NEVER ENDING.
IN THE MIDDLE OA
eporter: RIGHT, K THT LESSON TO
TAKE AWAY FROM ALL THIN "BE"G TI
WHATEVER THEY NE PAIR COVER, TO
ESE UNITS.
PUT THEM IN TANK
FOMOVE THESIS IT'S URGENT.AT PU
ABL
THIS.
IT IFFTON
AND FRANKLY,ORHAT'A
G PROPOSITION.
AS THI DRAWN OUTTHERE IS
HE'S USING SOCIAA TO TRY E GHE'P
USINGN OUR . POTRT
MEDIA.
SO W TO BETHE ALHE.O DR AS YO T.
EMPHASIZE.
HOW FAR IS PUTIN GOING TTAKE  D.
IT IS OBVIOUS THAT ESSENTIALLY .
IT GIVINS TO
THLITARY AND GIVING MORE
POWERSE FS
THE GOVEOR A ROLE  WILL BE MILI